want some extra bee sauce on your WTF
well you're in luck ready set go
wait toad what are you doing I Oh clever
taking advantage of a games glitch to
shorten your lap time is one thing but
patience is another see that guy over
there let's shoot some arrows way up
into the air yeah okay good now let's go
talk to him have a nice casual chat time
goes by nothing suspicious is happening
who except you know what what goes up
must come down but really why be so
crafty when you can just force it like
getting your puppy to eat eat it Duke
Nukem always had great dancers but by
adding in the high-res pack I can feel
even more um lonely in the real world
walls of death and moshing look like
this but in Assassin's Creed it happens
like this
or if romance is more your style there's
always crisis
you can also make the dancing happen
yourself by physically lifting a game
cartridge interrupting the flow of data
when you do that things like this occur
but don't worry you can always escape in
your plane or use more sophisticated
tools and calculate the most
advantageous position and action for a
character at every moment tool assistant
runs like these in many cases are the
fastest way you can beat a game without
using a cheat that's why it looks like
Jesus picked up a controller prefer
horror
sometimes when the Sims crashes kids
grow up but they keep their infant
bodies the result is a terrifying
stretched out baby who turns into a
black creeper when it goes indoors but
as we all know the only thing scarier
than Sims mutants is land sharks or is
it let me know in the comments below
what you think the scariest animal is
grizzly bears on horseback cats on crack
I don't know you tell me
and if you haven't done this already
click here to play Rusty's interactive
game are you nerd enough Fallout New
Vegas even you have what it takes we'll
check it out it's awesome and let me
know how you did and as always thanks
for watching